le césar de la meilleure réalisation est
attribué à roman polanski pour j'accuse
vendredi dernier lors de la soirée des
césars l'équivalent des oscars pour les
français roman polanski a remporté le
prix du meilleur réalisateur pour son
film
j'accuse sur l' affaire dreyfus en
france ce qui a provoqué de vives
réactions plusieurs spectateurs surtout
spectatrice sont sortis de la salle en
colère outré de ce que ce prix
prestigieux soit remis à un homme accusé
d'avoir violé des femmes et à l'époque
du mythe ou est ce qu'on peut parler de
leurs produits séparés en fait l'oeuvre
de son auteur dans ce contexte peut-on
présenter le film de polanski
ici au québec et au canada j'en discute
avec deux hommes c'est au hasard c'est
comme ça louis dussault qui est
président directeur général de cas film
américain distributeurs de films au
canada mais se dit souvent soir ainsi
qu'avec mario fortin qui lui est
directeur général dé cinéma beaubien du
parquet du musée des cinémas on peut le
dire de répertoire qui montrent en
général de très bons films bonsoir à
tous les deux bonsoir
alors d'abord on a voulu que ce soit une
espèce de débat monsieur dussault vous
en tant que directeur de caféine
distributeurs vous n'avez pas acheté le
j'accuse pour les distribuer au canada
pourquoi pas on nous l'a montré
effectivement au bureau on a beaucoup
plus minces un film extrêmement
important qui montre le début de
l'antisémitisme en france qui va donner
un sens par la suite pensé à tout ce qui
va se passer les années 40 et c'est la
fumée est important mais je suis très
simplement
ce qu'une de mes amis résa triste
française a envoyé hier vendredi par
dont elle était à la soirée des césar
audry diwan qui a réalisé le film mais
vous êtes fous qui a été présenté
derrière au cinéma beaubien
audry m'a dit maintenant que l'artiste
artus et les briques quelqu'un veuille
bien s'occuper de l'homme alors tout est
là je crois expliquez-moi comment vous
voyez ça l'artisanat est célébrée donc
il mérité son prix je pense que c'est
pas je sais pas moi c'est pas l'homme où
l'artiste c'est le film et nous on se
dit oui il l'a fait mais là mais il n'ya
pas d'acceptabilité sociale au québec
pour diffuser ce film là dans nos salles
au québec comme distributeurs de films
je suis pas seulement en affaires ou un
business je suis aussi en culture
surtout l'éditorial de k films amérique
c'est vraiment du cinéma d'auteur et on
n'est pas d'accord culturellement de
diffuser un film contre la vague nitoo
je pense que la vague nitoo dites ou par
respect à cette vague
jamais on ne pourra diffuser un film
avec un réalisateur toxiques mais c'est
forcé vous au contraire tant que film
arrivera au pays
vous allez montrer au beaubien s'il
arrive aux péris parce que c'est pas
encore fait c'est pas encore chose faite
ya pas de distributeur qui se sont
commis et je comprends très bien les
distributeurs d'être très prudents
d'être frileux mais être frileux oui
parce que quand on regarde qu'il faut
parler il faut laisser parler les
chiffres à un moment donné et puis quand
on regarde les revenus potentiels que ce
fumeur pourrait générer par rapport aux
prix sans doute faire un mini que les
français veulent avant parce que quand
même fait un million quatre cent mille
entrées oui mais c'est ça avoue pays où
il est contesté
ou alors il a il est extrêmement
populaire voilà et c'est un petit peu
notre position
je suis pas tout seul à faire le choix
des films et quand on regarde ça nous ce
qu'on se dit c'est que on ne peut pas
censuré on peut pas décider à la place
du client s'il peut ou ne peut pas voir
un film en lui interdisant l'accès dans
nos salles
donc si le film nous est présentée si on
a de la place dans notre rang on pourra
voir et peut-être lui faire une place et
perd ce moment là si les clients sont
pas au rendez vous et vous y verrez
peut-être vous n'êtes pas sûr je ici si
le film est effectivement disponible au
canada est ce que vous allez le diffuser
vos bons bien au cinéma du parc
on va regarder les conditions qui nous
sommes encore de distributeur et qui
apprécions vers ainsi si on a une place
l'enfant
et puis on va le faire mais avec
énormément de prudence il ya énormément
de 11 à viser nos clients on va les
informer de la situation
on va les réseaux sociaux pas ou est ce
qu'en france où le film a été diffusé on
prévenait les clients du contexte dans
lequel
ce film-là sort est ce que pourquoi tant
de précautions tout à coup parce que
c'est pas la première fois que des
oeuvres d'art qui sont contestés que il
ya des artistes qui sont condamnables
comme personne comme humain comme homme
ou femme mais il y à l'oeuvre qu'on
continue ainsi on devrait sont sûres et
tous ceux qui dans l'est s'il ya un film
anti avortement qui était enfin bien sûr
police est un réseau social
exploitant celle qui a accepté que si
vous trichez goudjo tous les autres
exploitants se sont rassurés il ya un
tabou et il ya je crois que c'est
intéressant et c'est prometteur de
savoir qu'il ya des tabous de ce genre
moi je me suis en 1987 mais on s'entend
que là le sujet du film était
controversée et son financement aussi
parce qu'avec des évangélistes derrière
un mobile politique derrière ce film là
et là on parle d'une oeuvre d'art dakar
a mis tout le sujet n'est pas
controversé n'ont pas de sujet mais
culturellement il ya tout le mouvement
mis tous derrière et c'est à mon avis à
notre avis à café une amérique suffisant
pour que renault on n'accepte pas de
distribuer ce film au québec mais ce que
c'est pas aller plus loin que ce que les
français aux faits eux les français ou
les accusations de viols ont été
déposées contre polanski pas plus tard
qu'en novembre dernier juste en avant
dernier en france et pas encore juger et
juste accuser il n'a pas été jugé
coupable
et pourtant le montrer en france nous
ici au québec où il n'y a pas
d'accusation contre polanski n'est pas
encore jugé on serait plus frileux que
ne le sont les français m'a cependant
question depuis le fait en tout cas de
naissance on ne construit plus complet
faire de la question une fois je répète
ce que j'ai dit au début de l'entrevue
ya pas d'acceptabilité sociale pour
paraphraser notre premier ministre
concernant le pétrole
bon c'est pas du pétrole bien entendu le
20 mai ce que vous est-ce que c'est
moralement c'est est ce que ce n'est pas
de votre part quand vous décidez de ne
pas le montrer et vous au contraire vous
vous semblez vous n'avez pas dit
clairement vous alliez de montrer que
vous aviez l'air vous si je lis pas vu
moi contrairement à lui donc je peux pas
décider
la première bardage sûr qu'il ya
beaucoup d'arguments mais on vient de le
vivre ça il ya quelques semaines
quelques mois avec le film de patrick
bruel et fabrice luchini pour le
présenter dans temps des fêtes
il ya beaucoup de nos clients qui nous
ont envoyé des courriels des messages
facebook tous ceux qui disaient pourquoi
vous présentez un film avec patrick
bruel qui il allait aussi vous l'avez
vous serez formés parce qu'on a laissé
les clients décider alors est ce que
c'est de leur libre choix
est-ce que c'est pas intimement monsieur
dessous je me reprends à vous est-ce que
c'est pas ultime en eau aux gens qui
vend ou ne vont pas au cinéma de décider
écoutez c'est une bonne question
moi je suis distributeurs de films moi
j'achète j'achète pas des films je
décide et j'ai décidé que je n'achèterai
pas incluse à l'art alors on verra bien
si les canadiens y auront accès
finalement mais ce fortin monsieur
dessous merci beaucoup d'être venu ce
soir si merci